[Musica]
è incredibile pensare che l'uomo ha
camminato sulla luna spirito satelliti e
sonde spaziali su altri pianeti
eppure ancora oggi facciamo molta fatica
a capire quello che succede sotto i
nostri piedi
esattamente 50 anni fa nasceva la teoria
della tettonica a placche quella teoria
che un po tutti abbiamo studiato a
scuola e si ricorda come il guscio
esterno della terra la cosiddetta lido
sfera è suddivisa in tanti pezzi le
placche tettoniche appunto le quali
formano un gigantesco un gigantesco
puzzle
oggi sappiamo che le placche tettoniche
si muovono sulla superficie terrestre ad
una velocità che è simile a quello con
cui vediamo crescere le unghie nelle
nostre mani
le placche si muovono si avvicinano e
talvolta si scontrano formando c'è anni
e catene montuose lunghe centinaia di
chilometri come le alpi e gli appennini
questi processi
se vengono nell'arco di milioni danno il
movimento delle placche e lento costante
e tuttavia però in certi momenti in
alcune aree del mondo
questi movimenti possono venire in
maniera improvvisa quando le rocce si
rompono libera una parte della loro
energia sotto forma di onde sismiche le
quali si propagano fino in superficie
generando scosse e quindi il terremoto
ogni volta che la terra trema e un sisma
provoca dei danni ci poniamo sempre la
stessa domanda ma perché la scienza non
è in grado di prevedere questi eventi da
oltre un secolo i geologi e sismologi di
tutto il mondo cercano di individuare
segnali affidabili che ci consentano di
anticipare di ore o di giorni da cadere
di forti scosse dal terremoto di messina
e reggio calabria del 1908 in cui si
pensa abbiano perso la vita più di 120
mila persone
la scienza ed in particolare la
sismologia italiana ha fatto passi da
gigante studiando cause e conseguenze
dei principali terremoti italiani che da
allora sono stati tantissimi
e credetemi nessun segno premonitore è
stato trascurato dalle emissioni di gas
radon all'irrequietezza degli animali
domestici
fino a pochi anni fa avevo un'idea molto
confusa dei terremoti
poi un giorno giulio di toro professore
di fisica dei terremoti all'università
di padova mi disse che i sismologi
avevano studiato sostanzialmente i
terremoti basandosi sull'analisi delle
onde sismiche per capire come nasce e si
propaga e muore un terremoto questo è
l'equivalente di voler capire come
funziona il motore di una macchina
semplicemente ascoltando nel rumore se
chiudiamo gli occhi ascoltiamo questo
rumore possiamo capire la posizione
della macchina quanto grande è questa
macchina e forse in che direzione si sta
muovendo
questo approccio però in realtà non ci
consente di capire realmente come
funziona quel motore quel motore appunto
che genera terremoti a chilometri di
profondità negli anni quindi si è
cercato di trovare un sistema che ci
consentisse tra virgolette di alzare il
cofano della macchina di terremoti per
vedere come funziona ed io come molti
altri colleghi sono stato attratto dalla
semplicissima e banalissima curiosità di
capire quel processo fisico che genera
così potenti ma allo stesso tempo
invisibile ai nostri occhi la ricerca
italiana è sempre stata all'avanguardia
in questo tipo di studi sono state
create per esempio in laboratorio
macchine che simulano lo sfregamento fra
rocce facendo scorrere le rocce come
avviene in natura sottoposte ad
altissimi tassi di pressione siamo stati
più o meno alla viglia di produrre
quello che avviene nella crosta
terrestre
nonostante i risultati sensazionali
questo però non ci ha consentito di
prevedere i terremoti
e allora siamo andati alla ricerca di
un'altra soluzione che per esempio
arrivata dai satelliti che grazie alla
loro eccezionale risoluzione sono in
grado di vedere variazioni anche di
pochi centimetri del suolo terrestre
questo ci ha consentito di capire dove e
come il suolo e le montagne si spostano
prima durante e dopo un terremoto
purtroppo però anche questo non basta e
allora siamo andati alla ricerca di
un'altra soluzione che sfrutti
l'avanzamento tecnologico e che ci
consenta di simulare l'ambiente reale e
soprattutto ci consenta di tenere in
considerazione tutte le sue complessità
e anche l'ampissimo intervallo di scale
temporali che caratterizza i processi
geologici dai milioni d'anni come
durante la formazione di una catena
montuosa ai secondi come durante un
terremoto
e questa è una possibilità per esempio
arrivata da attraverso i modelli
numerici ma a che cosa sono i modelli
numerici sono dei modelli appunto
matematici basati su una serie di
complicate equazioni fisiche poiché
dobbiamo risolvere queste equazioni
numerosissime volte usiamo dei
supercomputer come quello che vedete
alle mie spalle il quale di sole queste
qua azioni per noi lavorando per giorni
senza interruzione
questi modelli hanno aperto un nuovo
campo di studio negli ultimi tre anni mi
sono immerso in questo tipi di modelli
sempre più realistici e sempre più
complessi questi modelli ci hanno fatto
hanno portato a risultati straordinari
ci hanno fatto vedere per esempio come
si muovono le sue le placche tettoniche
sulla superficie terrestre o come
interagiscono quelle grandi profondità
della terra o per esempio come si genera
un catastrofico tsunami e per quanto
riguarda i terremoti
beh questi modelli ci hanno detto che
quello che avviene lì sotto a 10 15
chilometri di profondità è estremamente
complicato
i fattori in gioco sono tanti e tutti
chi più chi meno influenzano le tensioni
che si generano fra le rocce
insomma c'è tanto lavoro ancora da fare
le difficoltà si basano soprattutto sul
fatto che non siamo ancora in grado di
capire se esistano veramente dei segni
precursori su base scientifica utili a
comprendere la magnitudo
l'epicentro è l'orario esatto la
montagna da scalare per noi scienziati
sembra sembra altissimo in questo
momento quasi infinita e soprattutto
questi limiti si basano sul fatto che la
scienza che studia i terremoti ha solo
una cinquantina d'anni è una scienza
giovane la scienza che studia i
terremoti non è inesatta è solo
incompleta tuttavia però c'è un quesito
che vorrei condividere con tutti voi
ma è davvero importante è sapere quando
si verificherà il prossimo terremoto
certo questo aiuterebbe a salvare molte
vite
però invece di aspettare che la scienza
venga da noi ci dia delle previsioni noi
che cosa possiamo fare la soluzione c'è
esiste e se l'abbiamo tutti noi
si chiama prevenzione e quando parliamo
di prevenzione nel caso di terremoti non
è un aspetto solo tecnico ma anche un
aspetto sociale e culturale
la prevenzione uno strumento bellissimo
potentissimo che va usato bene
soprattutto con costanza e tutti noi lo
possiamo usare attraverso l'informazione
la preparazione e la formazione la
scienza deve avvicinarsi ai cittadini ed
io come giovane ricercatore ho capito
che parte degli sforzi di dovrei
dedicare proprio lì alla prevenzione
rendendo partecipi cittadini attraverso
la sensibilizzazione anche se fossimo in
grado di prevedere i terremoti non
eviteremo che le case crollino e oggi
sappiamo che la scienza messo a punto
tecniche di difesa che sappiano essere
efficaci soprattutto in caso di eventi
sismici importanti e fare in modo che le
case restino in piedi anche con
terremoti di magnitudo superiori a 8
sogno perciò un piano su scala nazionale
di consolidamento antisismico serio
organico ed a condurre su vasta scala e
che è necessario imporre senza eccezioni
non servono miracoli ma risorse perché
ricordate il terremoto non uccide
uccidono le opere dell'uomo per mettere
in sicurezza all'intero paese non
basteranno anni forse serviranno decenni
ma se non si comincia subito il
traguardo resterà sempre lontano
l'italia ha bisogno di noi dobbiamo
prenderci cura di noi stessi delle
nostre famiglie ma anche della memoria
storica che ereditiamo custodiamo e poi
tramandiamo alle generazioni future
grazie
[Applauso]